cher journal je me demande s'il est
possible de trop aimer quelqu'un par
exemple je crois que j'aime un petit peu
trop mon chien je laime comme mon propre
fils j'ai bien conscience que c'est un
petit peu bizarre je me souviens encore
quand il était tout bébé et que je lui
donner le sein savage rigole à la haye
où on peut plus rien dire ou quoi
pourquoi est-ce que je lui parle comme
si c'était un enfant de 29 mois
d'ailleurs pourquoi parle-t-on comme ça
un enfant de 29 mois
c'est bizarre et surtout la vraie
question à quel âge est ce qu'on arrête
de parler en mois
je me demande si mon chien ressent la
même chose pour moi
ou peut-être qu'il se dit que c'est
quand même sacrément rôle ou que je le
sorte à 23 heures tous les soirs pour
pas qu'ils puissent contrôler le canapé
pendant la nuit et ils fascinent et lui
aussi par les discussions philosophiques
que j'ai avec les maîtres de ses
congénères culpabiliser style de me
faire acheter des croquettes à la viande
pour le nourrir alors qu'il sait très
bien que je suis végétarienne
trouve-t-il normal qu'avec son budget de
jouets qui font plus de bruit que je
pourrais juste part loué une chambre de
bonne à paris me regarde-t-il dormir lui
aussi en se disant que finalement je
suis bien plus efficace que tous les
antidépresseurs qu'on a pu lui prescrire
at-il le coeur serré
ou bien qu'on style simplement à sa
prochaine tournée de croquettes bio sans
céréales à 190 euros le gramme
qu'on prend t'il que ma place c'est sur
mon lit et pas dans son panier pourtant
je ne perds pas mes poils je comprends
pas sincèrement je ne comprends pas
pourquoi menace pas augmenté
[Musique]